et comme chaque lundi nous allons parler
culture nous devons une page la culture
avec et sephora namani sephora qui nous
a rejoint en plateau bonsoir à vous vous
venez me présenter aujourd'hui pascal
amoyel est ce que je le prononce bien
oui tout à fait il offrait un spectacle
samedi soir à l'espace est philippe
noiret des clayes-sous-bois oui pascal
amoyel c'est ce pianiste virtuose que
vous entendez aussi bien sur france
inter france musique radio france et
radio classique il faut savoir que c'est
très tôt qu'il a montré des aptitudes
pour l'improvisation en clavier au
clavier sans même pour autant l'avoir
étudié on écoute quand j'avais une
dizaine d'années j'étais en train de
faire mes gammes chez moi et c'est la
gardienne de mon immeuble qui est venu
frapper à ma porte et qui m'a dit je
t'entends jouer du piano
sais tu que dans le même immeuble il y
avait un grand pianiste appelé georges
cziffra et qui vient juste de déménager
il a ouvert une fondation pour les
jeunes à senlis et tu devrais peut-être
aller le voir c'est peut-être ton destin
alors cette rencontre elle est vraiment
déterminante dans la vie de pascal
amoyel car john george's chiffre à vos
présentera pour lui toute sa vie un
mentor d'ailleurs dès son plus jeune âge
pascal amoyel suite ci fera aussi bien
en france et en hongrie tout en
exécutant parallèlement un parcours
musical rigoureux des dix ans il
commence ses études à l'école normale de
musique de paris il en sortira avec une
licence de concert et entrera derrière
ou conservatoire national supérieur de
musique et de danse où il obtient en 92
un premier prix de piano puis même un
premier prix de musique de chambre et
même le premier prix du concours
international des jeunes pianistes de
paris c'est d'ailleurs pour lui le début
d'une carrière internationale qui l'a
mal à se produire en récital sur les
plus grandes scènes du monde alors la
philharmonie de berlin la cité de la
musique la salle pleyel à paris aux
états unis en russie avec l'orchestré
symphonique d'état de moscou également
ou encore en chine au japon et en 2005
pour pascal boyer c'est vraiment la
révélation au grand public en remportant
une victoire de la musique dans la
catégorie révélation soliste
instrumental et son palmarès ne s'arrête
pas là en 2007 son enregistrement
harmonies poétiques et religieuses de
liszt a été élu par la chaîne arte parmi
les cinq meilleurs disques de l'année en
2009 son interprétation des funérailles
de liszt et sélectionnés par le magazine
classica comme l'une des quatre
références historiques donc vrai ce
n'est pas rien et enfin en 2010 à
l'occasion du bicentenaire de la
naissance de chopin un grand prix du
disque décerné tous les cinq ans par la
prestigieuse société frédéric chopin à
varsovie pour son intégrale des
nocturnes de chopin donc c'est
véritablement un virtuose au
contemporain il est moderne aussi parce
qu'il s'est investi dans la création de
formes nouvelles de concert tout à fait
alors après le concert théâtral qu'il
avait écrit et bloc 15 ou la musique en
résistance qui a fait l'objet d'ailleurs
d'une adaptation pour france télévisions
il a créé pour le festival de musique de
la chaise dieu en 2010 quand même qu'il
a représenté le ministre de la culture
de l'époque frédéric mitterrand est la
petite fille du célèbre pianiste
hongrois isabelle ci fera donc
l'incroyable destinée de jogging cyfra
où le pianiste aux cinq ans doit un
hommage donc à son mentor cet enfant des
bidonvilles du cirque de budapest
devenus soldats hongrois en résistance
prisonniers chez les russes envoyés en
camps d'internement et puis qu'on
connaît par la suite pianiste virtuose
dans les bars de budapest dès 1947 avec
la carrière internationale et donc
pendant tout le spectacle il va raconter
l'histoire incroyable de ce virtuose
c'est un spectacle que j'ai créée en
2010 au festival de la chaise dieu qu'à
créer george's cyfra et on m'avait
demandé de faire un hommage
un hommage à cet homme et je me suis
pris un peu au jeu spectacle musical pas
simplement d'un récit donc c'est
vraiment un spectacle et privés comme
des cours de comédie avec un acteur avec
christian fromont notamment qui est le
metteur en scène du spectacle
et voilà ça a donné une forme inédite et
je suis très très heureux de pouvoir
donner ce spectacle à la fois dans des
lieux d'un des festivals de musique
aussi dans des lieux où il n'y a pas
forcément de musique classique comme au
festival d'avignon tayrac turan lave et
cetera alors pourquoi justement avoir
pensé à un concert théâtral alors selon
lui ça lui permet justement de partager
davantage la musique classique de casser
les codes qui peuvent peut-être en
décourager certains de la rendre plus
accessible et ça lui permet également
d'intégrer des lieux dans lesquels on
n'attend pas forcément la musique comme
des théâtres il a joué à guichet fermé
au théâtre du ranelagh à paris ou même
des festivals comme celui des lignes ont
tous les pianistes n'a que dix doigts
ici se produit au pianiste pour cinq ans
de doigts
il a vraiment à coeur de partager cette
passion raison pour laquelle il est
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui professeur de
piano et d'improvisation au
conservatoire de rueil malmaison pour
s'investir auprès du plus jeune public
et pour ceux qui souhaiteraient
l'heureuse le retrouver dans un exercice
similaire et la clé fin 2015 un deuxième
spectacle le jour où j'ai rencontré
franz liszt
mon cher frédéric chopin
moi je suis en train de vaincre le piano
ou
le fait chanter
il faut savoir que la notoriété de franz
liszt était tel que à côté elvis presley
ou les rolling stones ne feraient pâle
figure
franks n'est pas heureux dans cette vie
de pianiste à 15 ans il va dire à sa
mère qui veut abandonner le piano
il se sent peu à peu aspiré par le
silence et donc tous ces effets sont là
pour prolonger un petit peu toute la
poésie et même le roman ksf
et vous pouvez retrouver toutes les
dates de la tournée internationale de
l'art ti sur son site à l'adresse et qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
beaucoup sephora 12 avoir dressé le
portrait de celui qui s'est vu décerner
en 2012 le prix jean pierre bloch de la
licra récompensant un artiste et son
oeuvre dans son rapport aux droits de
l'homme il a été nommé chevalier dans
l'ordre des palmes académiques de 2014
on vous retrouve mercredi dans kiosque
tout à fait et on parlera du festival
des clés du cinéma festival avec les
sous bois